you know one of the questions we've been
asking during this historic anti-vaccine
era uh around the world because of the
covet vaccines is is it going to is
anti-backs going to start to bleed over
to more General vaccine opposition not
just the covet vaccine what about
measles what about MMR and others and so
far the answer appears to be
unfortunately yes and this was very
predictable there's a good article in
the guardian measles cases surge nearly
80 percent
in the wake of coveted chaos with fears
other diseases could follow UNICEF says
viruses Canary in the coal mine that
shows up I think I think it's supposed
to say shows us the gaps in vaccination
campaigns for preventable illness
measles cases have surged nearly 80
percent worldwide amid disruption caused
by covet the UN says the coronavirus
pandemic has interrupted vaccination
campaigns for non-covet diseases around
the world creating a perfect storm that
could put millions of children's lives
at risk
a measles is a disease caused by a virus
that attacks mainly children
vaccination uptake of at least 95
percent is the way to avoid it spreading
some countries fall short of that goal
Somalia at just 46 percent
there's also concerns about whether
yellow fever could search there are
concerns about the Ukrainian Invasion by
Russia and the effect that that could
have the UN says 57 vaccination
campaigns in 43 countries have been
postponed
so this is focusing on access but the
problem is we saw outbreaks in the
United States of measles before the
covet pandemic so the point here is
basically twofold because of the
pandemic there have been campaigns of
vaccination that have been interrupted
and they tell us how quickly you can see
outbreaks of something as contagious as
measles which in particular uh is a
problem among children in the United
States a big sort of battle line on the
anti-vaxx front is the vaccination of
children before we even had the coveted
vaccines in this controversy we had some
pretty good size measles outbreaks there
was the Disneyland one in California
there were some religious sects in New
York City where we were seeing outbreaks
there was one in Italy a couple others
that I can't remember these outbreaks
were in part based on the idea that
parents didn't want to vaccinate their
kids now with measles understand how
critical that is particularly when it's
so contagious that you need to be
vaccinating 95 percent it is a concern
right now that we are going to start
seeing as more and more kids come up for
vaccination boosters for other diseases
or as more and more kids are born and
it's time for them to get the shots that
babies get in the first six months
we are almost certainly going to see
some more General vaccine hesitancy on
the basis of covet vaccine hesitancy and
it's going to lead to more of some of
these diseases and the measles
pre-covered example is one of the best
ones just small areas where they said I
don't I don't want to vaccinate my kid
against measles and they had outbreaks
and it's very serious for kids
um it could get very very bad and so
while on the one hand we're fighting the
vaccination battle uncovered
specifically there's this other more
General anti-vax thing that is beneath
the surface and we've heard from
something you know look at the
interviews we've seen from Trump rallies
where parents say well it's it's not
just the covet vaccine I'm getting my
kids off of all of these vaccines or
sometimes they call them they say
they're injections they're not strictly
speaking vaccines
this could get very bad very quickly and
we should be paying close attention to
the numbers from all over the world
we'll have uh more about this story on
our Instagram make sure you're following
us there at davidpackman show we'll take
a quick break we'll look at the White
House correspondence dinner we'll look
at a few other things be right back